laughs then one of the next questions is
how how do I protect myself from dinner
I think the questions are related so how
do you protect yourself from zina the
reality is number one number one
everyone listen to this it's not what
you think I'm going to say okay
self-restraint restrain yourself you can
restrain yourself I mean I had a
fourteen-year-old come to me not so long
ago how do I protect myself from zina I
want to get married
come on be a little bit realistic you
got to protect yourself you restrain
yourself sob sob or come on your day
will come when we were young we also
used to look at the opposite sex
sometimes and think when will I ever get
married today mashallah you know we've
got children of our own Michele I'm
sitting on about eight children by the
will of Allah Salah so subhanAllah to be
honest to you you have to protect
yourself
that's what Supper is all about you
reward the reward you're going to get is
for abstaining from prohibition that's
the reward so not only your Salah and
your zakat that's doing good deeds but
abstaining from bad is also a reward so
here's your opportunity stay back
however the hadith speaks about fasting
so you will fast fast every Monday and
Thursday fast rice that's right you know
three times a month the young will be
the 13 14 15 of the lunar calendar and
so on this will help you concentrate
have good company good company really
goes a long way in protecting you from
adultery don't find yourself Thank You
sugar on ten minutes how did that drop
straight from 30 to 10 Habibi chef I
suggest you don't lift it let someone
else do it here
mashallah you will have to face
everybody here because it's a
distraction chair we know the time is up
don't worry we're now on overtime you
know when a match is being played
football and it's zero zero you know
what happens they allow you how many
minutes Moshe I think we have 20 minutes
21 no I think it's more than it's about
45 minutes it's a whole - Elena meta
Charla yeah 2,200 minutes each we have
that this is more important than
football do you agree guys there we are
we have we a democratic they have voted
mashallah okay so what we need to do
subhanAllah is protect ourselves have
good company read a lot of the Quran go
into lessons try and expand your
religious learning
watch out how you use your phone how you
use your phone I want to tell you
something sad
many of us feel we're in love with
someone because of the phone but the
person in real life I have come across
so many who've got married as a result a
few have been happy but a lot say it's
not who I thought it was you know why
today like you have Photoshop you also
have a clock shop which means somehow
their luck is shocked you think that
they're really amazing and when you live
with them they ignore you they're on the
phone with someone else and you start
thinking so don't be deceived by the
phone you know when someone says I love
you Allah so many of them are just
saying it because it's just like saying
hello hi how are you and you know what I
love you means sometimes nowadays I want
to use you that's what it means I
promise you I promise you it means that
have you seen what I've said once some
time back on Twitter I said if people
can say long without laughing they can
say I love you without loving and I
think a lot of people caught on that but
I want to add something else today and
tell you a lot of the people say I love
you and actually mean without you
knowing I just want to use you and
because women are generally you know
emotionally they get more attached it's
sometimes the youth the young men who
are abusing this attachment so be
careful abstain be strict on yourself
you fast you have good company and you
try and engage in more acts of worship
go out and become a volunteer help your
help there and subhanAllah when the time
is right then you start opening your
eyes and I have one statement for a lot
of the brothers and sisters who are not
married subhanAllah and that is before
you are married don't close your eyes on
to one person
as tough as that sounds as tough as it
sounds once you're engaged then you
close your eyes done because maybe Allah
doesn't want you to marry the person
because they are bad horrible or maybe
Allah doesn't want it because something
might go wrong with the children that
couple will have and you don't know
so maybe unless keeping you apart I'm
not saying don't try you try you speak
to your parents you convince them you
can even change your wilayah if you want
you know what that means this is my
willy he's my father I will go to the
panel of scholars and tell them my
father is blocking my marriage without
any reason so I want to marry without my
dad and if you're if you qualify for
that you can actually shift that wilayah
to a well ii will be someone else who
will it be that panel of scholars in an
islamic country you'd have the Carvey or
someone who would represent you as a
wali so they'd be the person becomes a
wali of yours so you need to be careful
because sometimes if you do that and you
know that the person you want to marry
is not standing on their own two feet in
terms of you know finances and so on you
might have to come back to your family
one day and they might not want you at
that stage I think most families do take
you back but why should we do that may
Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala grant to see
so if you want to protect yourself from
zina there are steps the hadith speaks
of fasting and lowering your gaze today
people watch movies and watch this and
you know what we see all these tutorials
hijab tutorials are being watched by the
male's I don't know what for hijab
tutorials and therefore would you and
say did you see this hijab you know is
this the camel hump brother there's a
hump in your head man may Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala forgive us what are
you worried about this thing here for
take it easy
let the sisters go ahead and have a peep
but then you look at your wife and you
say you know I saw the tutorial I think
you need to look a bit like so-and-so
you know so-and-so
may Allah forgive us so this is why we
don't lower our gaze and we don't
realize lowering the gaze is very
important even when it comes to the
screen I know you know you always get
wisecracks in the youth sometimes they
say but Sheikh I'm lowering my gaze
looking in the screen you know I'm
lowering my gaze that's not what it is
you know what I mean you don't look at
these things by the will of a line if
you do you know you are allowed to say
Masha Allah
you know if you really have great
intentions you can even say inshallah
but it's okay that's where it stops I
love we got two more questions inshallah
I need to get these out the way brother
so please bear with us it won't be long
and Sharla
but before I learned the question I just
want to mention a story regarding how
the families reject proposals because of
their color
there was a story where a brother a
rancher brother from Africa who came to
ask for a sister's hand and the family
rejected based on his color and
unfortunately this sister ended up in
the future time committing zina with a
non-muslim and becoming pregnant and
unfortunately when this story is told
you know a parents get shocked and I'm
sure this pit that the parents of this
sister was shocked as well but again you
need to ask yourself a question when
your childhood wanted to do in a halal
way halal manna brought her brother home
in a respectful way and you reject him
based on color and your daughter now and
this is true story when and became
pregnant by a non-muslim and then what
does the parents call they bang their
head against the wall oh Allah where did
I go wrong
what like you went wrong by being racist
and the reason why I'm telling this
story is because we deal with the youth
we get these messages this is one of the
biggest problems that's why I really
want to you know speak from aunties and
uncles please for the sake of Allah make
it easy on the youth the worst thing is
when they use Islam to justify
themselves how you know you've been
brought up in a similar environment
that's good enough Subhan Allah I can
tell you another true story I'm going to
have to word it very carefully because
of the what exactly happened there was a
sister who wanted to marry a man from
Africa and she was an Asian so basically
the parents said no and there was a big
issue and you know so many things were
discussed and she was quiet and a while
later the parents came to me and told me
please can you convince this daughter to
marry the same guy and I'm like but
what's wrong country just speak to him
know you don't know what's happened now
one year had passed approximately and
this sister came up to
her parents and told them that I want to
marry someone and you know who that
someone was another sister so
subhanAllah
what happened is the parents now are so
worried and they said bring the man no
matter who he is and where he's from
bring him on Subhan Allah may Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala grant us an
understanding may Allah Subhanahu WA
Ta'ala open our doors
I'm not commenting further but I'm sure
you've understood ok quickly and one of
the questions that need to be answered
is how can I get to know somebody in a
halal manner because unfortunately a lot
of you think that Islam is you don't see
the person you want to marry it's just
you may you meet on the wedding day and
Hollis you get married and obviously we
know that's not the case how could one
go about getting to know the opposite
gender in a halal manner
I should shoot you